si vraiment mon père quatre classes et
si on regroupe tous les éléments 30 35
c'est toutes vos conditions de travail
qui qui se dégrade
enseignants parents d'élèves élèves et
quelques élus ils sont près de 200
mobilisés sur le marché de toucy quatre
classes doivent fermer aux scènes du
collège et du lycée
tous ici redoute des conséquences
néfastes sur la scolarité
nous estimons que c'est pas des
conditions d'enseignement satisfaisante
pour nos élèves que ça allait fragilise
que ça ne permet pas un suivi
individualisé
ça rend bien sûr très compliqué les
cours de langues les tp en sciences etc
et donc on nous sommes très inquiet les
manifestants ont aussi dansé une
pétition elle a déjà recueilli près de
1500 signatures
le cortège défile au milieu des étals et
traverse la commune pour se rendre
jusqu'à la cité scolaire dans les
rendent certains sont venus en famille
tout comme les enseignants les parents
eux aussi sont inquiets
si le cadet de leurs soucis
les élèves restent des premiers
concernés pour eux des classes
surchargées auront forcément un impact
négatif une baisse des résultats est
baisse de l'obtention du bac
donc voilà maintenant faut privilégier
la réussite plutôt que l'économie là on
et 28 dans là dans ma classe donc
surtout avec certains élèves qui sont en
difficulté j'imagine pas à 30 voire même
plus comment on peut apprendre avec
autant de personnes dans une classe une
journée collège mort et un blocus de la
cité scolaire de tous y sont prévus
mardi
d'autres établissements se sont aussi
mobilisés à tonnerre en silo francs ou
auxerre plusieurs délégations doivent
être reçus la semaine prochaine à dijon
par le rectorat qui justifie ces mesures
par une baisse de la démographie